FELLOW REPUBLICANS IN THE
SENATE.
LISTEN, THE POLITICS OF THIS ARE
VERY TOUGH FOR BIDEN --
>> SORRY TO INTERRUPT, WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP TALKING ABOUT
THIS, BUT IT'S A BUSY DAY ON
CAPITOL HILL.
GOING BACK TO THE HEARING WHERE
JOSH HOLLY, THE REPUBLICAN IN
MISSOURI IS QUESTIONING MARK
ZUCKERBERG.
>> -- IN THE LAST SEVEN DAYS.
I KNOW YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
THTHESE STAL STATS BECAUSE HE S
AN EMAIL WHERE HE LINED IT ALL
OUT.
WE GOT A COPY OF IT.
MY QUESTION IS WHO GOT FIRED
BECAUSE OF THAT?
>> RSENATOR, WE STUDY THIS
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT.
>> YOU JUST SAID THERE'S NO
LINKAGE.
WHO DID YOU FIRE.
37% OF TEENAGE GIRLS BETWEEN 13
ADD 15 WERE EXPOSED IN UNWANTED
NUDITY IA WEEK ON INSTAGRAM.
YOU KNEW ABOUT IT WHO DID YOU
FIRE?
>> SENATOR, THIS IS WHY WE'RE
BUILDING ALL THE TOOLS.
>> WHO DID YOU FIRE --
>> SENATOR, I DON'T THINK THAT'S
THE BEST.
>> WHO DID YOU FIRE?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO ANSWER THAT.
>> YOU DIDN'T FIRE ANYBODY,
RIGHT?
YOU DIDN'T TAKE ANY SIGNIFICANT
ACTION?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO TALK ABOUT
INTERNAL DECISIONS THAT --
>> IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE.
DO YOU KNOW WHO IS SITTING
BEHIND YOU?
YOU'VE GOT FAMILIES FROM ACROSS
THE NATION WHOSE CHILDREN ARE
EITHER SEVERELY HARMED OR GONE,
AND YOU DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO TALK ABOUT STEPS
THAT YOU TOOK?
THE FACT THAT YOU DIDN'T FIRE A
SINGLE PERSON.
>> I'M NOT --
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS, HAVE YOU
COMPENSATED ANY OF THE VICTIMS?
>> SORRY?
>> HAVE YOU COMPENSATED ANY OF
THE VICTIMS, THESE GIRLS HAVE
YOU COMPENSATED THEM?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
>> WHY NOT?
DON'T YOU THINK THEY DESERVE
SOME COMPENSATION FOR WHAT YOUR
PLATFORM HAS DONE.
HELP WITH COUNSELING SERVICES?
HELP WITH DEALING WITH THE
ISSUES YOUR SERVICES CAUSED?
>> OUR JOB IS TO MAKE SURE WE
BUILD TOOLS TO HELP KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO COMPENSATE
THEM?
>> SENATOR, OUR JOB AND WHAT WE
TAKE SERIOUSLY IS MAKING SURE WE
ARE BUILD INDUSTRY LIVING TOOLS.
>> TO MAKE MONEY.
>> TO TAKE IT OFF SERVICES AND
BUILD TOOLS THAT EMPOWER
PARENTS.
>> SO YOU DIDN'T TAKE ANY
ACTION, YOU DIDN'T TAKE ANY
ACTION, YOU DIDN'T FIRE ANYBODY.
YOU HAVEN'T COMPENSATED.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, THERE'S
FAMILIES OF VICTIMS TODAY, HAVE
YOU APOLOGIZED TO VICTIMS?
WOULD YOU LIKE TO NOW, HERE ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION, TO
APOLOGIZE TO THE VICTIMS WHO
HAVING HARMED?
SHOW HIM THE PICTURES, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO APOLOGIZE FOR WHAT
YOU'VE DONE TO THESE GOOD
PEOPLE?
>> -- FOR THE FAMILIES THAT HAVE
SUFFERED THIS IS WHY WE'VE
INVESTED SO MUCH HERE, TO MAKE
SURE THAT NO ONE GOES THROUGH
THAT.
>> NOW, WHY, MR. ZUCKERBERG, WHY
SHOULD YOUR COMPANY NOT BE SUED
FOR THIS?
WHY IS IT THAT YOU CAN -- YOU
HIDE BEHIND A LIABILITY SHIELD,
YOU SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
WOULDN'T YOU BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, WILL YOU TAKE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY?
>> SENATOR, I THINK I'VE
ANSWERED THIS.
>>TRY IT AGAIN, WILL YOU TAKE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY?
>> SENATOR, I VIEW MY JOB, AND
THE JOB OF OUR COMPANY AS
BUILDING THE BEST TOOLS THAT WE
CAN TO KEEP OUR FAMILY SAFE.
SENATOR, WE'RE DOING A INDUSTRY
LEADING SERVICE.
>> NONSENSE.
YOUR PRODUCT IS KILLING PEOPLE.
YOU'RE A BILLIONAIRE, WILL YOU
SET UP A COMPENSATION FUND WITH
YOUR MONEY, WITH YOUR MONEY --
>> SENATOR THESE ARE COMPLICATED
ISSUES.
>> THAT'S A YES OR NO.
WILL YOU SET UP A VICTIMS'
COMPENSATION FUND WITH YOUR
MONEY, THE MONEY YOU MADE ON
THESE FAMILIES SITTING BEHIND
YOU, YES OR NO?
>> SENATOR, I DON'T THINK
THAT'S -- MY JOB IS --
>> SOUNDS LIKE A NO.
>> MY JOB IS --
>> YOUR JOB IS TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR WHAT YOUR COMPANY HAS DONE.
YOU'VE MADE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON THE PEOPLE SITTING BEHIND YOU
HERE.
YOU'VE DONE NOTHING TO HELP
THEM.
YOU'VE DONE NOTHING TO
COMPENSATE THEM.
YOU'VE DONE NOTHING TO PUT IT
RIGHT.
YOU COULD SO TODAY AND YOU
SHOULD, YOU SHOULD,
MR. ZUCKERBERG.
BEFORE MY TIME EXPIRES,
MR. CHEW, LET ME JUST ASK YOU,
YOUR PLATFORM, WHY SHOULD YOUR
PLATFORM NOT BE BANNED IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, YOU
ARE OWNED BY A CHINESE COMMUNIST
COMPANY -- THE COMPANY BASED IN
CHINA, THE EDITOR-IN-CHIEF OF
YOUR PARENT COMPANY SAY
COMMUNIST PARTY SECRETARY.
YOUR COMPANY HAS BEEN
SURVEILLING AMERICANS FOR YEARS,
ACCORDING TO LEAKED AUDIO FROM
80 INTERNAL TIKTOK MEETINGS,
CHINA-BASED EMPLOYEES FROM YOUR
COMPANY HAVE REPEATEDLY ACCESSED
MATERIAL OF UNITED STATES
CITIZENS.
YOUR COMPANY HAS TRACKED
JOURNALISTS IMPROPERLY GIVING
ACCESS TO IP ADDRESSES, USER
DATA, TO IDENTIFY WHETHER
THEY'RE WRITING NEGATIVE STORIES
ABOUT YOU.
YOUR PLATFORM IS BASICALLY AN
ESPIONAGE ARM FOR THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
WHY SHOULD YOU NOT BE BANNED IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
>> SENATOR, I DISAGREE WITH YOUR
CHARACTERIZATION.
MANY OF WHAT YOU'VE SAID IS
EXPLAINED IN A LOT OF DETAIL.
TIKTOK IS USED BY 170 MILLION
AMERICANS.
>> EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
AMERICANS ARE IN DANGER FROM THE
FACT YOU TRACK THEIR KEYSTROKES.
YOU TRACK THEIR APP USAGE.
YOU TRACK THEIR LOCATION DATA.
AND WE KNOW THAT ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION CAN BE ACCESSED BY
CHINESE EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
SUBJECT TO THE DICTATES OF THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY.
WHY SHOULD YOU NOT BE BANNED IN
THIS COUNTRY?
>> SENATOR, THAT IS NOT
ACCURATE.
A LOT OF WHAT YOU SAY IS NOT
CORRECT.
>> IT'S 100% ACCURATE.
DO YOU DENY THAT AMERICANS'
MATERIAL HAS BEEN ACCESSED BY
BYTEDANCE IN CHINA?
>> WE HAVE DONE THAT AND MADE A
LOT OF PROGRESS.
>> AND IT HASN'T BEEN STOPPED,
ACCORDING TO A "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" FROM YESTERDAY, EVEN
NOW BYTEDANCE WORKERS WITH
ACCESS TO DIFFERENT CHANNELS --
I'M QUOTING, PRIVATE INFORMATION
OF AMERICAN CITIZENS INCLUDING
THEIR BIRTH DATE AND IP ADDRESS.
THAT'S NOW.
>> SENATOR, THE MEDIA DOESN'T
ALWAYS GET IT RIGHT.
>> BUT THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY DOES?
>> I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
WE HAVE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
BUILD THIS PROJECT, IT'S
RIGOROUS, ROBUST AND I'M PROUD
OF THE WORK THAT THE EMPLOYEES
ARE DOING TO PROTECT THE DATA.
>> IT'S NOT PROTECTED, THAT'S
THE PROBLEM, MR. CHEW.
IT'S NOT PROTECTED AT ALL.
IT'S SUBJECT TO CHINESE
PROTECTION.
YOUR APP, AND HEAVEN'S KNOWS
I'VE GOT PROBLEMS WITH EVERYBODY
HERE, BUT YOUR APP, UNLIKE ANY
OF THOSE, IS SUBJECT TO CONTROL
AND INSPECTION OF A FOREIGN
HOSTILE GOVERNMENT THAT HAS
ACTIVELY TRIED TO TRACK THE
WHEREABOUTS OF EVERY AMERICANS
THEY GET THEIR HANDS ON.
YOUR APP OUGHT TO BE BANNED IN
THE UNITED STATES FOR THE
SECURITY OF THIS COUNTRY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN.
>> SENATOR CORONA.
>> THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN.
AS WE'VE HEARD, CHILDRACE
ALL SORTS OF DANGERS IN SOCIAL
MEDIA --
>>> AS WE CONTINUE TO LISTEN TO
THIS HEARING, WE JUST HAVE TO
SAY, WOW, WHAT WE ALL JUST SAW
LIVE ON TELEVISION IS GOING TO
BE A MOMENT FOR THE AGES, WHEN
WE JUST SAW SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY
ASK MARK ZUCKERBERG IF HE HAD
APOLOGIZED TO THE FAMILIES, MANY
OF WHOM ARE THERE IN THE
AUDIENCE.
AN AUDIENCE THAT THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE DICK DURBIN SAID
EARLIER WAS THE BIGGEST THAT HE
HAS SEEN IN HIS 22 YEARS ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
AND THEN MARK ZUCKERBERG STOOD
UP, TURNED AROUND AND SPOKE TO
THE FAMILIES.
HE WAS OFF MIC, SO WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT HE SAID.
I KNOW THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
SOME AUDIBLE TAPE OF EXACTLY
WHAT HE SAID.
BUT THAT MOMENT IS SOMETHING
THAT BELIEVE WE ARE GOING TO B